it is justice sheffield seeking his
first quality start since mid-may yeah
trying to bounce back after a rough
start in his last outing against
minnesota this will be his 13th start on
the year rymel tapia
in the midst of an 18-game hitting
streak
a little more charges has to get rid of
it quickly and he does
lead off man retired two outs for the
rockies shortstop trevor story over four
last night with three punch outs
swinging away on the first pitch
taylor tramell in center
parks underneath it
just to sheffield retires the rocky good
one in this game for the rockies hermann
marquez who takes the ball has been
pitching very well recently at the
bottom of the first inning mariners and
the rockies no score j.p crawford to
leave things off
the fall and the winner
swung on it missed
with two outs kyle seeger will try and
get something going for the mariners
and this is tapped out right to hamad
and he'll lob it to first hood harder
good inning took just ten pitchers to
get three out right fielder charlie
blackman will lead off the top half of
the second
and that's a four pitch walk to charlie
rogers batting 262 with three home runs
oh this ball hammered deep left field
did rogers click all of it
god
two rod home run brendan rodgers
fourth of the year for rogers and a
wonderful rocky start the rockies take a
two to nothing lead two rounds two runs
in nobody aboard for joshua fuentes
tries to check and he goes
commence on the slider sheffield strikes
out the side but gives up a two-run home
runs so story to step in from the right
side over one with a fly ball to center
field
oh boy stay
fair god that got out quick
[Applause]
the pride of irving texas story time in
seattle make it three nothing colorado
how loud was that
and the rockies build their lead to
three nothing blackman and at first
nobody out in the fourth in a run in on
stories homer three nothing rockies
this ball has lied to the gap in left
center field and it's off the center
field wall in fact charlie around third
gets a stop sign from stu cole
cj's did hit it too hard
that's the ninth double
for krone runners on it second and third
a run in two outs now
rocky's lead three nothing here is
joshua fuentes
he goes
the marathon is over justice a strikeout
14 pitches
marquez has retired the side in order in
each of the first three innings and
he'll go after
jp crawford
and this is an easy play for brendan
rodgers
lit up man retired in front of mitch
haniger
see you
that's unhittable it is that is the
fourth strikeout of the ball game for
hermione two outs here is kyle seeger
here's the one two
that ball was left up it's hit well to
right and charlie makes the catch
right in front of the wall wouldn't it
got out but uh that's the first uh ball
that came off the bat hard against
terrebonne three nothing colorado
rocky's lead by a score of three to
nothing ty france a lead off the inning
this is bounce to the right side krone's
got it
and he feeds perfectly the catcher
torrens
he grounded out his first time up seven
ground ball outs for marcus burned in
five innings
this ball is clubbed to left and right
down out there by tapia
five perfect innings for herman marcus
it's vermont marquez comes in with a
five and six record a four two six here
all he's done has been perfect through
the first five innings taylor tremell
the hitter two out nobody on
hangs and drives one right field back it
up blackman on their track jumping and
gone there it is
home run for taylor tremell is sixth of
the season
15th run batted in arizona board it's
3-1 colorado bottom six first hit of the
ball game and it breaks up the perfecto
trevor's story is a home run in three
tries
this ball to center field well struck
and deep got a chance another home run
trevor story that's exactly what the
rockies needed
now they're up five to one a two homer
afternoon in seattle for trevor story
that's a great day to be a story
another story to add in another chapter
did that in 2015.
and there's the back foot slider long
tumbles to the ground and he also
gets a red card and a pink slip
[Music]
dylan shoots this out towards the
alleyway tapia is man he has just gotten
to just about everything over there
today
he's been covering some ground and he
takes the hit away from dylan moore
carlos is up on the mound he will face
9-1-2 in the mariner's order
two outs crawford at second it's up to
seeger
and seger is bunting
crawford home
they giveth and seeger take it give it
to me there's nobody there and
may as well take advantage of it can you
just keep it fair and keep it away from
the pitcher that's not a problem he can
walk to first
[Applause]
here's national league comeback player
of the year daniel bard two one two out
five two rockies in the ninth
one two pitch to bowers swag and a miss
got him with some high g's
and that's the ball game
rockies gain a split here in seattle
behind a great afternoon from airmon
marcus
final score
rockies five mariners two